führt uns die eiszeit vor rund 460
millionen jahren auf einen riesigen
crash im asteroidengürtel zwischen mars
und jupiter die eiszeit vor eben 466
millionen jahren genau hatte es in sich
das klima auf der erde kühlte sich
drastisch ab und ein schwedisches
forschungsteam hat jetzt herausgefunden
wodurch diese kälteperiode ausgelöst
wurde
ursache ist wohl ein katastrophales
ereignis im asse ii den gürtel zwischen
mars und jupiter und ohne das wäre
unsere erde heute nicht so wie sie ist
krieg zum science fiction hier gibt's
täglich spannende science wie es
abonniert den kanal und aktive die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen das ist eine
ziemlich spannende erkenntnis 460
millionen jahre ist es her dass wohl ein
katastrophales ereignis im
asteroidengürtel zwischen mars und
jupiter stattgefunden haben muss eine
aktuelle studie eines forschungsteams
aus schweden geht davon aus dass damals
ein etwa 150 kilometer große asteroid
nach einer kollision zerbrochen ist und
das hatte fatale folgen auch für die
erde ein drittel aller meteoriten die
auf die erde fallen können wohl auf
diese asteroiden katastrophe
zurückgeführt werden auch heute noch
diese erkenntnis schließen die fachleute
aus einer analyse von gesteinsschichten
aus dem auto vici um beim ordovizium
handelt es sich um eine
erdgeschichtlichen epoche die vor etwa
485 millionen jahren begann und 42
millionen jahre anhielt schon seit
längerer zeit ist bekannt dass die nun
analysierten gesteinsformationen aus
südschweden und russland viele kleine
fossile meteoriten aus dem mittleren
ordovizium enthalten
auch diese können wohl auf die
katastrophe damals im asteroidengürtel
zurückgeführt werden doch nicht etwa
zahlreiche kleine meteoriteneinschläge
lösten damals die eiszeit aus sondern
eine weitere folge die der weltraum
crash mit sich brachte im klartext staub
staub staub eine extraterrestrische
staub schwämme traf der erde wohl mit
voller wucht zu bürger schmitz der an
der aktuellen studie beteiligt war
man kann dies vergleichen mit dem effekt
der eintritt wenn ich mitten in meinem
wohnzimmer einen vollen
staubsaugerbeutel platzen lassen
meterdicke ablagerungen zeugen noch
heute davon dass es sich damals wohl um
achtung 4 bis 40 millionen tonnen staub
gehandelt haben muss er auf die erde
herunter gegangen ist zum vergleich pro
jahr sind es derzeit etwa
40.000 tonnen weltraum staub der auf die
erde kommt und diese gigantische menge
an staub fiel zudem sehr lange an zwei
bis vier millionen jahre lang hielt
dieser staub ein strom auf der erde
demnach an auf diese spektakulären
ergebnisse kommen die fachleute durch
die analyse von helium und osmium
isotopen in den ablagerungen und dass
solch ein gigantischer staubschleier
auswirkungen für das leben auf der erde
hat ist klar
die sonneneinstrahlung auf der erde
namen extrem ab der staub schluckte
wärme und licht doch nicht nur das dazu
schreibt das autorenteam zudem wurde
nach dem zerbrechen des asteroiden nicht
nur die erdatmosphäre staubiger sondern
auch ein großteil des interplanetaren
raums im inneren sonnensystem das
schirmte die erde noch stärker vom
sonnenlicht ab die algenblüte in den
ozean nahm zu denn der weltraum staub
wirkte hier wie dünger auch das führte
dazu dass die temperaturen auf der erde
deutlich abnahmen dazu der us-forscher
philipp heck unsere ergebnisse zeigen
zum ersten mal dass solcher stoff in der
vergangenheit die erde dramatisch
abgekühlt haben kann das gleichmäßig
tropische klima auf unserem
heimatplaneten veränderte sich es
entstanden viele verschiedene klimazonen
und auch eis an den polen diese
kälteperiode im mittleren ordovizium
ließ neue arten entstehen nach ansicht
von fachleuten gab es damals womit die
so viele lebewesen wie heute und das zum
ersten mal in der erdgeschichte kein
wunder denn durch die klimaveränderung
entstanden neue ökologische nischen
doch die fachleute sind nicht sicher ob
die kosmische katastrophe der einzige
auslöser für die klima abkühlung war
oder ob diese vielleicht nur als
verstärker diente denn andere studien
hatten andere mögliche ursachen für die
eiszeit vor 466 millionen jahren
gefunden unter anderem die drift des
urkontinent gondwana über den pol oder
aber die auffaltung der appalachen ein
gebirgs systeme im osten nordamerikas
möglicherweise kamen auch mehrere
klimawirksame faktoren zusammen weitere
studien müssen folgen um diese rätsel
ganz auf die schliche zu kommen
objekt aus einer fremden welt traf die
erde anklicken anschauen und neugier
zone unbedingt abonnieren ein richtig
richtig richtig cooler kanal also bis
dann bleibt dran